there are two types of questions in the
English language attacking questions and
buying questions you don't defend
against attacking questions by answering
them you attack the attacking questions
by responding to them with a question
that attacks the frame of the originator
so whoever asks the question who's
always in control of the conversation
buying questions you answer because
those are things around Logistics like
what happens next how do I sign this
contract but if someone says tell me
more about your experience that is an
attacking question because they want to
deframe you and so then you have to ask
and attack the frame of their question
so you say What specifically you're
looking for as long as you keep the
other person answering you are in
control